scientists at New York University have
discovered a new pathway for stimulating
nerve insulating myelin which is damaged
by multiple sclerosis that will
hopefully lead to restoring and
protecting nerve function and vamp is a
solar-powered hypersonic entry vehicle
designed to collect data in the
earth-like mid cloud environment of
Venus hey Vsauce Kevin here this is my
100
researchers in Sweden have created a
cyborg
plant a liquid solution that included a
polymer was sent through the xylem of
the plant forming a solid wire that
conducts electricity while still
allowing the plan to transport
life-sustaining water and nutrients the
xylem wires enable organic
electrochemical transistors to convert
chemical signals to electronic output
meaning future uses could include
storage systems that convert sugar
produced from photosynthesis into
electricity all happening inside plants
this video shows how they can change the
color of a leaf by manipulating the
conductive material inside the half no
clone lets you touch Holograms
tella haptics allows users to send a
holographic image at another person can
actually feel and interact with the box
uses ultrasonic radiation pressure to
create the feeling of the holographic
image but the produced force is
generally weak if it were strong enough
to feel like a solid object the
ultrasound would damage your nerves but
the system allows you to virtually touch
fingers with someone in real time a
computer learning algorithm can detect
liars researchers at the University of
Michigan in Ann Arbor fed the algorithm
121 trial videos that included speakers
expressions and gestures along with
whether they were convicted of perjury
it correctly identified the
truth-tellers 75% of the time with
humans managing just 59 and a half
percent and the very best interrogators
reaching 65 percent meanwhile scientists
in Bristol have developed urine powered
microbial fuel cell socks based on the
circulatory system of fish
it doesn't require a powered pump like
previous attempts all it needs is pee
they say it could serve a proof-of-life
function for military or outdoor gear
because it's capable of transmitting a
message wirelessly only functions if the
person is alive and peeing laser pipe is
a snake-armed robot that uses
high-powered lasers to weld stuff so
yeah Connexus is a project that uses
magnets on fingertips to explore virtual
worlds the fingernail-sized
electromagnets are tracked by magnetic
sensors and unlike camera based tracking
systems it doesn't
acquire a clear view of your hands it's
also a much more immersive way to
perform VR input than by using a plastic
controller researchers from the
University of Washington are now focused
on adding more sensors and miniaturizing
the system possibly by creating a glove
filled with electromagnets and a
wristband to house the sensors plant
lamps provide light sources for people
living in the rain forest without using
gasoline or oil they utilize the free
electrons generated from the oxidation
process of plant produced nutrients in
contact with microorganisms in soil to
power the LED lamps which is awesome
over the past five years mind blow has
uncovered several innovations that have
gone on to experience huge success
like nest a smart thermometer featured
in mind blow fifty one two years later
it was bought by Google for 3.2 billion
dollars we've also witnessed the very
beginning of ideas that were later
implemented on a massive scale mind blow
39 uploaded in April 2012 showcased the
pizza button a Bluetooth fridge magnet
from red tomato pizza that automatically
ordered a VIP customers favorite pizza
in 2015 Domino's announced emoji
ordering just tweet them a pizza emoji
and your order is on the way
various augmented reality systems have
been featured throughout the years like
invoked computing which could turn
household objects into input devices
gravity space which tracked users with a
pressure sensing floor and caneta which
animated everything
well Amazon was just recently awarded
patents for an augmented reality system
that projects images in a room that
users can interact with using gesture
controls a concept for a smart highway
highlighted in mind blow 53 features
blowing the dark lines that would absorb
light and emitted glow for eight to ten
hours after a trial in early 2014
changes were made due to rain affecting
the glowing lines and a new moisture
resistant paint was used the new smart
highway finally went public with
glow-in-the-dark lane markers and a
glowing bicycle path there are now plans
to launch glowing lanes in Japan and
China if you've watched all 100 episodes
of mind blow you've spent around seven
hours learning about stories which in
just one video
range from newblue but monkey and
acoustic levitation to GPS shoes and
tallest mohawk if you've thought mind
blow is called mind-blowing this entire
time that could be an example of para
praxis a slip that occurs when the brain
is trying to come up with a word or name
and simply selects what it deems to be
the best match but regardless of how you
remember the name you've all come
together to view mind blow over 228
million times so here's to the future of
cutting-edge science here's to the next
100 episodes and as always thanks for
watching
meat flavored water pea butter a new
toilet that can flush golf balls the n64
upside down looks like a koalas face a
robot designed to scratch your itch an
octopus chair a plasma ball watch edible
spray paint a beehive for your apartment
a 27 pound lobster a dress boat a $1,000
ice Popp and this robotic bear pillow is
designed to tickle your face to stop you
from snoring and it produces
contractions and the intestines that we
leave chronic constipation and a kid
want a lollipop thermometer and a
hummingbird feeder for your face and
guitar ping and a giant brain phone
booth and say hello to the newly
discovered blue butt monkey and a snake
cake and a 1 million dollar gold vacuum
with a rap song
go back goons one may be dolla it's
gonna make you have a kid in New Zealand
recently found a chunk of whale poop
worth $65,000 like the Internet Internet
here's the most detailed picture ever
taken of Uranus half bad half dog and
extinct for 9 million years it's bear
dog who's hungry for a solid chocolate
baby had newly discovered loris Czech
brand new species check extremely cute
Czech venomous teeth check this is a
hummingbird hawkmoth bones of a new
dinosaur were found in Utah and they
kind of looked like a cow and a
triceratops had a baby tweet pea lets
parents know when their baby has pee
this robot tells you if you have bad
breath I'm a moth and here I am I'm a
moth and now I'm a tree on land or on
sea and ther B is RV sorry it's a mind
blow wait what's a mind blow Oh
I've been waiting for you Vsauce new
sauce have come to protect Kevin from
the t1000 uh terminator
I was just finishing mind blow can we
meet I'm gonna leave you with a biped
robot that corrects its balance if you
push it I'm gonna leave you with a
robotic ape transitioning from a
quadrupedal to a bipedal posture I'm
gonna leave you with a thousand robot
swarm that self assembles into shapes
I'm gonna leave you with a humanoid
robot autonomously playing the metallo
phone I'm gonna leave you with a
gymnastic robot landing a quadruple
backflip off a bar I'm gonna leave you
with a superhydrophobic knife cutting a
water droplet in half and as always and
as always and as always thanks for
watching thanks for watching thanks for
watching we'll see you there come out oh
one well as always thanks for watching